اذا حماس وتحدي ومواجهه من العيار الثقيل
يسعى من خلالها المنتخبان الارجنتيني
والكرواتي الى تحقيق غايته مع ببلوغ
المباراه النهائيه لمونديال قطر
2022 في ملعب لوسيل مباراه مصيريه قد تغير
ميزان الكفه بين لاعبين محترفين
ارجنتينيين وفي مقدمتهم ميسي وكرواتيا
المقتظه باللاعبين القتاليين بقياده
مودريتش حيث ستكون هذه المواجهه الثالثه
بين الارجنتين وكرواتيا في كاس العالم
والاولى من نوعها في الادوار الاقصائيه
راقصوا التانجو هذه المره سيكونون امام
فرصه كبيره لكسر احت- احتكار القاره
العجوز لللقب منذ العام 2006 الهيمنه
المنتخبات الاوروبيه على النسخ الاربعاء
الماضيه بتتويج ايطاليا عام 2006 اسبانيا
عام 2010 والمانيا في عام 2014 وفرنسا في
عام فين وثمانيه عشر فالمنتخب الارجنتيني
لطالم قدم مستويات ونتائج منطقيه وضعته
على راس المرشحين للفوز بالبطوله قبل
بدايتها وقد وصلت الى نصف النهائي بعد ما
اطاح بالمنتخب الهولندي بركلات الترجيح في
الربع النهائي بينما اثبتت كرواتيا انها
من الكبار بعدما كانت طرفا في نهائي
مونديال النسخه الماضيه لتعود وتبلغ نصف
نهائي مونديال الدوحه بعد اطاحتها
بالعملاق البرازيلي في الربع النهائي وفقه
مراقبين مشاهدينا جميعا على احتمالات
متاحه في مواجهه اليوم حيث يتطلع المنتخب
الارجنتيني للوصول لنهائي كاس العالم
للمره السادسه اما المنتخب الكرواتي فقد
يكون رابع منتخب اوروبي يصل للنهائي في
مرات متتاليه بعد طبعا ايطاليا وهولندا
والمانيا
[موسيقى]